all right he is an actor comedian and
best-selling author of recovery freedom
from our addictions Russell Brand is
over here
[Applause]
[Music]
oh I'm so glad you got the leather pants
on you haven't you haven't abandoned all
your rock star [ __ ] right I thought at
least one person on this panel should be
wearing faux leather attire I have to
say I am a really big fan of yours no no
I'm never kind
I'm always truthful oh yes because
sometimes you work imagine Li yes here
in America I am but and I must say I
feel like there was a time when I saw
you a lot oh and lately not to hover by
my window and lately I don't see you
enough how can I get the right amount of
Russell Brand in my diet this is the
classic addiction dilemma we have a
little bit and then we get carried away
and we can't control it our inability to
moderate well what happened was I think
became immersed and engulfed in the
intoxicating drug of celebrity drank and
drank from from the cup like Icarus to
flew too close to the Sun burned myself
terribly and then retreated to the
British countryside to look at wild fowl
I mean you got interested in life which
is something a lot of people who are
addicted to I mean years ago we did an
issue famous the worst drug of all I
mean you see it the way people hang on
unreality shows and stuff I mean you
used to be a star and now you're on an
island eating bugs you know like
anything anything would be worse than
giving up that Fame and as you're an
addiction specialist would you concur
with that that famous as bad as the
other ones I'm an expectant I've
experimented on myself quite ruthlessly
and quite extensively not in laboratory
conditions more's the pity I could have
done with someone in a lab coat to give
me a cuddle and a petri dish would have
been useful but what I do agree with
bill is reason times where we live on
the outside external phenomena is
stimulated us to a ludicrous degree and
the addiction is just the amplification
of consumerism if you constantly
broadcast at people that they ought be
afraid if you constantly broadcast the
people that
ain't good enough and that they can
purchase somehow externally the feeling
of well-being then addiction for me is a
natural conclusion of this phenomena
[Applause]
I ain't gonna [ __ ] with that that's yeah
I was gonna say you did write a book
about it and you've had all the
addictions that you've done all the
drugs oh and what was your favorite
heroin is very very relaxing - relaxing
you let go of your life in the end LSD
is delightful to annihilate the concept
of self the construction of self the
biochemistry biochemical tapestry
stimulated by a culture formulated in
memory to see that thing bust apart by
hallucinatory to behold to experience
oneness to experience it's a connection
to know that in truth we are all one I'm
glad you're now so sane and healthy go
on
still marijuana which I believe you're
well-acquainted with you
cocaine a little too upbeat for me
terrible drug I can't take that stuff
and then turn it into rocks with
bicarbonate its soda just to do a bit of
extra jail time based on pigment and
bicarb that's no kind of deal so like
for me the only drug that I'm interested
in is the drug that we are pursuing in
the first place the drug of connection
of unity of love for me all these things
are placebos every drug every commodity
just a placeholder on the way force
idols as we seek out some kind of true
from connection in whatever time
denomination in whatever language
whether it's agnostically atheistic Lee
or religiously we're all looking for
oneness we're all looking for connection
and I think in your country at this time
we're seeing tumult and rage bubbling up
in the form of these peculiar figures
these ludicrous gargoyles that govern
these comedic figures that even your
parody cannot entirely do justice to
yeah you know I mean this this shooter
that we were talking about in Vegas it's
kind of a conundrum and he is it's kind
of what you're talking about it's a
person who they can't find a motive he
just seemed to have a hole in his soul
yeah he was rich he had a lot of money
he had a life in Las Vegas but there was
something horrible missing
it seems extraordinary that something so
malicious and malignant and awful can
occur with such frequency and it must be
the result of systemic problems not as
the result of individual problems
certainly that kind of analysis wouldn't
have been afforded a person of color or
of a different faith it would not have
been based upon their individual
positions so obviously about one more
addiction the instead you were also a
sex addict isn't there a different
[Music]
it's a difference between all the drugs
which you are physically addicted to and
which have harmful side effects what
what is what is the bad side effect of
sex addiction smiling well I did do
right grin there sir because I'm
juvenile and I'm on a television program
but addiction these are necessary
aspects of a healthy human life but I
would say the definition of addiction is
a behavior that you repeat that is
having detrimental effects and that you
cannot stop for me that is the
definition of addiction now initially if
your habit if it doesn't hurt you well
it only does hurt me and they only hurt
other people as a white heterosexual
who's attracted to adult human females
you hit a bottom more slowly than if you
had hit a bottom a lot the
objectification and commodification one
more thing I love you you're a beekeeper
I do keep and you know the bees you must
know then and you maybe you're doing
this for this reason that they're
endangered and people should know that
I've got sixty thousand of those bees
and every single one of them is nothing
but trouble necessary component of a
healthy ecology I was making a joke just
I can't take their honey bill out of
pure bloody guilt but yet right now I
know it's great that you don't steal it
yeah cuz you don't lift the lid off
their house it's upsetting right
excavator and you and you send them out
to to pollinate